I would say that the traditional
Catholic Ireland that I grew up in was
very much focused on the mail and
hierarchical structure starting with the
church itself but women on the whole
didn't work outside the home and women
couldn't serve on juries there were all
kinds of discriminations and many of
those I went into public life early to
tackle so I was trying to change those
circumstances from a very early stage I
think it was a combination of an inner
sense of justice in that sense that
women had just as much potential and
that i had the same potential as my
brother's which in fact my parents very
much encouraged well when i graduated
from trinity college in law i was
fortunate enough to go to the harvard
law school at a particularly interesting
time I'm the class of 68 so i was there
in 1967 and 68 and that was a time when
young americans were questioning the war
in Vietnam they were interested in civil
rights programs in the south san martin
luther king was assassinated that year
and robert kennedy just after i
graduated and I came back to Ireland
imbued with that sense that young people
can make a difference and I was elected
to the Irish Senate very shortly
afterwards and the first measure bill in
the parliament that I introduced to the
age of 25 was a bill to legalize family
planning it seemed me to be very simple
because married women were not allowed
to have the contraceptive pill unless
they had cycle regulation problems and
it must be in the weather but there was
a phenomenon of many married women
having cycle regulation problems and
also you couldn't buy or sell the pill
it was a criminal offense but if you
could manage to get a pill I sorry the
condom and you could use a condom but
not by our sellers and I felt this is
something that just needs to be
straightened out and I completely
underestimated the grave offense
and concern that I caused to a whole
range of people I was denounced by
bishops from priests from the pulpit and
I was denounced by newspapers I was an
outcast for a while and it was a very
troubling experience I I kind of wobbled
because I'd been used to being more or
less reasonably admired and liked I was
doing well and suddenly I was actually a
hate figure and got hate mail and it was
very good for me because I learned a
lesson that a few really believe that
something is important and it's true
then stick to it go through with it pay
the price be unpopular don't be arrogant
but sometimes you have to stick to your
principles the strange thing is I don't
remember when I didn't kind of have that
sense even as a small child with my
brothers kicking a football on the beach
as an asst grown near where near Balinor
where I was born I would break off from
the football and I remember having these
deep thoughts that there are things that
have to change that somehow we must make
it a fairer world and when I studied law
I didn't study law to be a lawyer I
studied law to learn how to use law as
an instrument for social change as a
barrister in court as a legislator as it
happened and as a teacher I loved to
teach law not in a narrow sense but
again as an enabler of Justice I'm still
teaching law linking human rights and
globalization
I think I have a particular framing at
the moment which is that we got our
values for the world at a time when the
world was extraordinarily anxious after
two world wars Holocaust nuclear
explosions on citizens in Japan and
beginnings of a cold war and then we got
this commitment as a birthright look at
the world today in my lifetime I think
I've never seen a point where we're as
anxious we have the divides since nine
eleven poverty divides ideological
divides we have nuclear proliferation
right back on the front burner with the
link may be too dirty bomb threats
through terrorism we have all of that
and what we're doing to our world the
climate change issue so never have we
needed those values as much and as Mary
Burke growing up in the West of Ireland
I didn't know what my life would would
me know or wherever it bring me I also
had the influence now I think about it
of several nuns of the family maybe that
was also part of that sense of having a
mission in life but I do feel that the
world desperately needs to regain a
sense of common shared values and I put
human rights of the heart of those
values but not narrowly not just rights
to fair trial no torture getting rid of
Guantanamo Bay and all the rest of it
but also writes to food and save water
health education dignity dignity and
worth of every human being if we had
lived up to the vision of 60 years ago
and had committed to everyone having the
birthright in reality of those rights
think of how much safer how much nicer
how much better our world would be
it's an old idea but the modern roots
are in the french constitution the
constitution of the united states but
from an international point of view the
great document is the universal
declaration of human rights and that was
the work of a small team of lawyers who
came from China the Lebanon from France
from Canada under the chairmanship of
Eleanor Roosevelt at the time she was
already the widow of President Roosevelt
and she was quite bossy she wasn't
herself a lawyer but she bossed this
team of eminent lawyers to write it in
straightforward simple language there
are only 30 articles is quite short at
the first article I think sums it all up
it says all human beings are born free
and equal in dignity and rights and
that's very interesting that dignity
comes before rights that sense of
identity of self-worth the fact that if
somebody's sleeping a cardboard box in a
doorway the worst thing for them is that
we don't see them it's not utter self
you know elimination the Universal
Declaration also talks in article 29 the
second last article about duties to
community it's like the ubuntu
principles or indeed most great
religions talk about that we are
connected with each other that we should
you know reach out to community it's
very important at the moment that we're
coming up to the 60th anniversary of
when that was adopted in Paris in on the
tenth of December 1948 so part of my
work in realizing rights and more
recently since I've become an elder of
Nelson Mandela and grasa Michelle the
elders have adopted the universal
declaration of human rights as part of
our framing constitution and we're going
to be trying to get people to re-read it
to think about it and to say this is the
birthright of children it includes
rights to food and save water and health
and education so we need to get on with
these Millennium Development Goals it's
a whole framing of values which is
universal it would it I'd say we just
wouldn't get as good a text today if we
brought people together to write her we
would be so compromised by
all the things that have happened
including the emphasis on security the
post-911 world the ideological divide
but we don't have to rewrite it because
every government has accepted it they
just haven't implemented
you